Nó ngay 1 mùi tháng 18, 2,5,
tổng công ty chình đến các Việt Nam,
Bên tế VHC, và tập đàn Mà Linh đã kiết hợp tác chỉ lực tò dịch.
Sức hiện nay, Mà Giá một dễ đạn hợp tác xấu dòng trên mọi lĩnh vực hoàn đầu của 2 bên,
tư trên thông, khoảng cáo, bởi vì đến vật tạng.
Nhằm tạo ra một hiện sinh thái xíc của yêu Việt,
má lại lợi cộng rủ cho cả 2 dân nghiệp cho khách hàng và cho cộng đồng.
Theo lợi dùng kiết, VHC sẽ trở thành đối tác chỉ lực và dưới cũng có 10 phụ quảng cáo,
trên thông trên tò nộ hiệp sinh thái kinh dân bình tạng của tập đàn Mà Linh,
bao gồm hệ thông xe và ứng dụ trên tòan quốc.
VHC được quyền tiếp cận và chiến thái các dịch phụ kinh dân đà dạng của mình,
đặc biệt là các xanh phẩm bảo hiệp tới mạng nơi phát khá,
các bộ nhiên biên và tệ xế dụng lưỡn của tập đàn Mà Linh.
2 bên cũng cảm kết xe dựng các chiếm bản chéo xanh phẩm,
dịch phụ tân dụ tập phát khá lưỡn của nhau để giá tăng hiệu quảng kinh dân
một dụng thị phần bấn cao giá chiếp thương yếu.
Tại bối lế, ông mùi viên 6, tổng giá đốc VHC sẽ xe hợp tắc sữa VHC và tập đàn
Mà Linh là sự kích hợp mang kính công rộn dựa 2 thương hiệu viết có độ phụ sống vào VHC xấu dọc.
Chúng tôi tin rằng bằng việc kích hợp thế mạnh về lỗi dụng,
trên thông của VHC với mạng nối vẫn tại và hệ sinh thái đà dạng của tập đàn Mà Linh.
Chúng ta sẽ tạo ra những giả chi mới, mang đến cho khách hàng những tránh nghiệm dịch phụ tự lợp,
im việc và đong có tích cửa đời sống xa hợp.
Ông hồ hồ hồ hồ hồ hồ hồ hồ thủ thị khổ đồng quảng chỉ tập đàn Mà Linh khẳng định.
Tập đàn Mà Linh không muốn lỗi lộ lực để mang lại những dịch phụ tốt nhất cho khách hàng và tạo ra
mua trường làm việc an toàn, cũng lợi cho đường mũ nhân viên.
Hợp ta chỉ lợp bằng dịch VHC, một đơn vịy tín chức thuộc đại chuyện nghiên Việt Nam,
sẽ giúp chúng tôi làm phòng phủ thêm hệ sinh thái của mình,
đặc biệt là trong những cuộc chuyên thông và các sĩ phụ ra chỉ ra tăng như bà hiểm.
Đây là bức đi chính lợp, phù hồp với định hưởng phát triển bình vũn và lấy quan người làm Trung tông của tập đàn.
Hợp ta chỉ lợp tạng dị này là nên tạng bướng chắc để viên tế vị khác và tập đàn Mà Linh chỉ khai các sự an cụ thị.
Cám kết trường thành đối tác lâu dài, cùng nhau phát triển bí lợi ít Trung của hai bên và cuộc đồng.